je suis dit ah bon soir mais on
concevoir alors là cette négociation
va-t-elle vraiment redémarrer demain
c'est officiel tout le monde est
d'accord c'est officiel j'ai proposé aux
organisations syndicales de les
rencontrer demain à 15h30 et j'espère je
crois les ennuis que bien sûr j'espère
et je crois que cette négociation
peut-être d'autres négociations
ultérieures permettront de trouver une
solution à ce conflit
alors justement on est sur des positions
de principe sur quelles bases peut-on
redémarrer négociation d'un côté on ne
veut pas de votre côté vous voulez faire
des économies comment peut-on trouver
quelque chose à négocier qu'est ce que
vous allez proposer
on a depuis le départ et le départ a
commencé il ya longtemps et a presque un
an
tous les éléments d'une excellente
négociations pour les pilotes
de quoi s'agit-il l'on vient d'entendre
ce pilote allemand qui disaient oui en
effet on accepter un certain nombre de
remises en cause en allemagne lorsque
c'est nécessaire pour l'entreprise il
faut savoir le faire c'est bien de ça
qu'il s'agit de l'avenir de l'entreprise
le 40 % d'écart de coûts et les pilotes
de lufthansa 20% et venir jouer ça n'est
pas supportable dans la durée et dès
lors qu'on a pour air france et je crois
que tous les personnels d'air france
selon un projet ambitieux un pour les
300 ça pouvait être développement un
projet d'avenir et bien au fond ce qu'on
dit aux pics de l'entreprise c'est
investissez dans votre entreprise
ayez confiance dans votre entreprise et
fait l'effort qui vous a demandé vous en
aurez les retours comme tous les
personnels c'est à dire que vous n'allez
pas renoncé à l'idée qui est la vôtre
des changes une baisse certaine forme de
baisses de salaires contre des actions
face à rien rien n'a changé dans un
manoir ya un objectif économique
cet objectif économique il est de
l'ordre de 500 millions de francs c'est
un objectif unique et propre
air france propre à la compagnie air
france ensuite sur les modalités
permettant d'atteindre cet objectif
les changes salir action j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire sur une base
volontaire le choisiront ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est vous le gel des
salaires d'une certaine façon où les
chandails pas à ce gel d
c'est pas le gel des salaires vous savez
les pilotes c'est pas un reproche à air
france continue les actes de carrière du
développement mort carrière qui se
produit en dehors de toute augmentation
générale de salaire ou des progressions
en moyenne de 4% par an leur carrière
tout organiser cette manière eh bien ça
consiste à lire aux pilotes d'alors
qu'on se fixe un objectif d'aller vers
une grille un petit peu inférieur
voyons comment on veut y aller en
maintenant garantissant à chacun le
maintien de son salaire et en
ralentissant ces avancements
alors est ce que pour revenir sur le
contenu même est ce qu a annoncé des
bénéfices alors ce qu'on veut réduire la
masse salariale est ce que c'était très
habile
c'est certainement plus difficile c'est
certainement plus difficile de
s'adresser à des personnels à une époque
où air france fait des bénéfices
importants et de leur dire si on veut
continuer à aller de l'avant il faut
encore continuer à faire quelques
efforts
mais je crois que tout autre discours de
la part du président de l'entreprise
sera un discours mensonger
si air france comme tous ses personnels
est d'abord les pilotes ont l'ambition
d'être parmi les très grandes compagnies
aériennes mondiales
alors il faut dégager les moyens pour
investir et les investissements c'est du
recrutement de pilotes les carrières
plus rapide c'est un avenir pour tous
est-ce que ce conflit finalement ne va
pas donner raison d'une certaine façon à
ce qu'ils voulaient entièrement
privatisé affronte crois pas que ce soit
le sujet vraiment pas je crois que les
entreprises publiques bien géré et on
doit plus privé mal géré mon ambition
celle du gouvernement dans un cas d'une
entreprise qui va ouvrir largement son
capital mais qui en effet restera public
c'est que air france soit une entreprise
bien gérée elle est sur un marché
concurrentiel et sur ce marché
concurrentiel
elle doit avoir les bases économiques
qui lui permettent d'y être présente
dans d'excellentes conditions question
pratique puisque le président d'air
france est ici présents demain le trafic
est encore paralysé de la même façon
qu'aujourd'hui
demain je crois que le trafic sera
encore difficile
on remettra peut-être
un certain nombre de vols et tronçon
supplémentaire dans notre programme et
je voudrais dire avec les images que
j'ai découvert avec vous notre journal
d'hier à l'ensemble des clients d'air
france que l'entreprise la compagnie
leur présente ses excuses mais leur dire
aussi que si le président de
l'entreprise disait on n'y arrive pas
bah tant pis les gens auraient peut-être
un avion ce week-end mais il n'est pas
certain que l'avenir c'est l'avion sera
encore des avions d'air france
dernière chose le mondial est-ce qu'il
est encore menacé ce soir ou es ce que
vous avez bon espoir que demain les
choses partent et je crois que tous les
tous les français sans exception et
naturellement les pilotes parti souhaite
que ce soit une grande fête
la grande fête du football mondial d'une
grande fête en france et je ne vois pas
qui prendrait la responsabilité de
gâcher cette grande fête qui par une
grève qui ne serait pas comprise merci
beaucoup
quelques numéros de téléphone utiles et
encore tout de même donc pour demain ou
dès de l'entente donc vous voyez sur
votre écran